Carlos Brody:
Oh, I've been a geek from a very early age.
When I was, I think, about 12
my parents, for my birthday,
Carlos Brody:
they bought me a programmable calculator.
And they hid it away, waiting for my birthday.
Carlos Brody:
But I found out that they bought it, and I found out
where it was.
Carlos Brody:
And so at night, when they were asleep, I would crawl out
of bed, and go to the closet
where they'd hidden it away,
Carlos Brody:
and open it, and play with
it, and learn to program.
Carlos Brody:
That's when I first learned to program.
And then of course, I'd wrap
it back up and put it back
Carlos Brody:
away, so that they wouldn't know
that I'd been doing this.
Carlos Brody:
And then when it came to
learning about the brain, it
Carlos Brody:
was like it turned out to
be the most incredible,
Carlos Brody:
complicated, huge programmable
calculator ever.
Carlos Brody:
So it's the same problem,
except it's so much more
Carlos Brody:
interesting and complicated.
I think a lot of neuroscientists get into it
Carlos Brody:
because it's us.
It's really about trying to
understand what makes us tick.
Carlos Brody:
There's 10 billion neurons
in a typical human brain.
Carlos Brody:
Each of those, on average, connects to
about a thousand others.
Carlos Brody:
So that's 10 to the 14 synapses,
10 to the 14 connections.
Carlos Brody:
We always say, "That's more stars
than there are in the
Carlos Brody:
known universe."
One of the reasons that I chose
to come to Princeton was
Carlos Brody:
because so many of my heroes
are here at Princeton.
Carlos Brody:
For example, John Hopfield.
I credit John with being the person who
Carlos Brody:
taught me how to think.
David Tank, who has developed
some of the most advanced
Carlos Brody:
technologies that we use to
study the brain, and is still
Carlos Brody:
doing so in a very exciting way.
And I knew, of course, that the
students were excellent.
Carlos Brody:
That was one of the things that brought me here.
It was a delight how intelligent
and how motivated
Carlos Brody:
and how serious about the work
a lot of the students can be.
Carlos Brody:
Because the brain is so crazily
complicated, and
Carlos Brody:
because it works at so many
levels, you can start studying
Carlos Brody:
the brain at the level of a
single neuron or you can study
Carlos Brody:
it at the level of a few tens of neurons.
Or you can study it at the level
of thousands of neurons.
Carlos Brody:
Or you can study it at the level
of behavior, in billions
Carlos Brody:
of neurons.
Those are many different ways
to look at it, and require
Carlos Brody:
many different ways of thinking.
Some of them require molecular
biology, some of them require
Carlos Brody:
psychology, some of them require
computer science.
Carlos Brody:
The brain, because of its nature, requires
interdisciplinary cross-level
thinking to make the advances
Carlos Brody:
beyond what we know now.
It's about exchanging ideas, no matter which
Carlos Brody:
department you're in.
And that has been a big part of
what promotes neuroscience
Carlos Brody:
here at Princeton, and what
makes me think, "Oh, we're
Carlos Brody:
really going to do something
special here."
Carlos Brody:
Understanding how the brain
works will have impact on
Carlos Brody:
philosophy, will have impact
on engineering, will have
Carlos Brody:
impact on health.
And here at Princeton, we're on
the cusp of producing those
Carlos Brody:
interdisciplinary links right now.
The best part about being here?
Carlos Brody:
The stellar intellects that you're surrounded by.
The challenge that that provides.
Carlos Brody:
There are a lot of people here
who are smarter than I am.
Carlos Brody:
That's where I want to be.
[music]